the 2022 golden globe awards are without
a network
and tom cruise is returning his trophies
all in response to the ongoing lack of
diversity controversy
with the hollywood foreign press
association here's what we know
i'm always kind of surprised with this
stuff you never know when it's going to
happen
on monday e.t confirmed that tom cruise
sent back his golden globe awards to the
hfpa
amid the continued backlash the
organization faces for its lack of
diversity
an issue that overclouded the show
earlier this year
and just hours later nbc announced plans
to break their long-standing
relationship with the hfpa
and the network will not be airing next
year's golden globes broadcast
nbc said in a statement quote we
continue to believe that the hfpa
is committed to meaningful reform
however change of this magnitude takes
time and work
and we feel strongly that the hfpa needs
time to do it right
as such nbc will not air the 2022
golden globes so what happens now
while the golden globes won't be on nbc
next award season
the ceremony could find a home on
another network or streaming service
but they run the risk of facing an empty
ballroom if the stars continue speaking
out
in february this viral image from the
time's up organization
highlighted the lack of diversity among
the hfpa
which is made up of journalists around
the world in response to a report from
the los
angeles times which first brought
awareness to the hfpa having
zero black journalists in their ranks
the organization said in a statement
quote
we understand that we need to bring in
black members as well as members from
other underrepresented backgrounds
and we will immediately work to
implement an action plan to achieve
these goals as soon as possible the
graphic was shared by stars like
sterling k
brown mark ruffalo and ava duvernay who
wrote on twitter
old news new energy hashtag time's up
globes
additionally scarlett johansson revealed
in a statement that she's often faced
quote
sexist questions and remarks by certain
hfpa members
that bordered on sexual harassment on
monday
et obtained a statement on behalf of the
board members of the hfpa which includes
a commitment to
systemic reform that is long overdue
quote
regardless of the next air date of the
golden globes implementing
transformational changes as quickly
and as thoughtfully as possible remains
the top priority for our organization
they also released an outline of their
course of action from now
until august focused on achieving reform
milestones
looking further into the ceremony's
future nbc
didn't say they're opposed to picking up
the broadcast again
pending the hfpa's response their
statement on monday also
said quote assuming the organization
executes on its plan
we are hopeful we will be in a position
to air the show in january 2023